We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. To vast and trunkless legs of stone stand in the desert. In Ozzy Mandius. Supposed by Percy Shelley.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。沙漠中矗立着两根巨大而无躯干的石腿。出自珀西·雪莱的《奥齐曼迪亚斯》。
The poem is about a historic monument of a figure. A shattered visage lies. Who has a wrinkled lip and a sneer of cold command the statue points to all the works around him and the poem reads my name is asi mandius king of kings king of kings look upon my works my words my de my despair and despair and the rest of the poem says that all of the works that the statue is pointing to have disappeared. Nothing beside remains.
这首诗是关于一个历史人物的纪念碑。一张破碎的面孔躺在那里。他有着起皱的嘴唇和冷酷傲慢的狞笑，雕像指向他周围的所有作品，诗中写道：我的名字叫奥齐曼迪亚斯，万王之王，万王之王，看看我的功绩吧，我的绝望，绝望吧。而这首诗的其余部分则说，雕像所指向的所有作品都已消失。周围什么也没剩下。
So it's really a poem about that the figure remains, but everything around it has disappeared. Everything that the figure in the statue was supposed to be proud of. But this is about another former statue that once stood high above San Francisco. This is kind of the inverse. All of the things around it, all of the landscape
所以这实际上是一首关于那个雕像人物依然存在，但周围一切都消失了的诗。雕像中的人物原本应该为之自豪的一切都消失了。但这讲的是另一个曾经高高耸立在旧金身上空的雕像。这有点像是相反的情况。它周围的所有事物，所有的风景
that this statue was supposed to sort of urge to liberty and philanthropy. That's all still here. The San Francisco, the statue was dedicated to improving, is there, but the statue itself is disappeared. That's William Littman. I teach architectural history at the California College of Art in Oakland and San Francisco. And we're walking up to what I think may be the greatest place in all of San Francisco that few people have ever heard of on what was once considered the geographic center of the city. So here we come up, it's this kind of raised plinth on top of Mount Olympus, a massive stone pedestal that rises up to nothing. It's the base of a statue that isn't there. Or once this 12-foot high bronze statue stood on top of it. On a site that has some of the best views of the entire city.
这座雕像原本应该激发人们对自由和慈善的热情。这一切都还在这里。这座雕像旨在改善的旧金山就在那里，但雕像本身却消失了。那是威廉·利特曼。我在奥克兰和旧金山的加州艺术学院教授建筑史。我们正走向上帝山，我认为这里可能是旧金山最伟大但极少有人听说过的地方，这里曾被认为是城市的地理中心。我们走上来，这是奥林匹斯山顶上一个凸起的基座，一个巨大的石底座，却通向虚无。这是一个已经不在了的雕像的底座。曾经有一座12英尺高的青铜雕像矗立在它上面。这个地方拥有整个城市最好的景色之一。
The view is insane. It's a 360 view of the city. The statue was called the Triumph of Light. It was a statue of this woman who looked a little like the statue of Liberty. She was holding a loft, a giant torch, the other hand she had a piece of parchment. And below her was a crouched figure, kind of reaching up to these two objects. As if it was symbolizing mankind, reaching for light and liberty. It was erected in 1887 by then developer and future mayor Adolf Sutro as a symbol of liberty and progressivism. When Sutro dedicated the statue in 1887 on Thanksgiving Day, he told the crowd, may the light shine from the torch of the goddess of liberty to inspire our citizens to good and noble deeds for the benefit of mankind.
景色太震撼了。这是一个可以360度俯瞰城市的视角。这座雕像被称为“光明的胜利”。这是一个女人的雕像，看起来有点像自由女神像。她高举着一个巨大的火炬，另一只手拿着一块羊皮纸。在她下方是一个蹲着的人形，有点像在向上够着这两样东西。仿佛它象征着人类对光明和自由的渴望。它是由当时的开发商、后来的市长阿道夫·苏特罗于1887年作为自由和进步主义的象征而竖立的。1887年感恩节，苏特罗为这座雕像揭幕时，他告诉人群，愿自由女神火炬的光芒照耀，激励我们的公民为人类的利益做出善良而高尚的事迹。
It was supposed to stand forever to be a timeless reminder about the importance of liberty and civilization and philanthropy. But it didn't last. In the 1930s, people were referring to it as the mystery monument. So obviously people have forgotten about Sutro and his goals. And then by the 40s, there's discussion about removing it. After decades of neglect, sometime in the 1950s, it just disappears. And people discuss it online where it may have gone, so no one knows.
它本应永远矗立，成为一个永恒的提醒，提醒人们自由、文明和慈善的重要性。但它并没有持久。在20世纪30年代，人们开始称它为神秘纪念碑。显然，人们已经忘记了苏特罗和他的目标。到了40年代，开始出现将其移除的讨论。经过几十年的忽视，在20世纪50年代的某个时候，它就这样消失了。人们在网上讨论它可能去了哪里，但没有人知道。
People really do come up to this hill. The same things that Drew Sutro here bring dog walkers and, you know, just urban walkers to come up here. Maybe through these kind of discussions, we can actually have someone maybe decide to build a new statue. I mean, who knows what it would look like though? Imagine the debates about how would you symbolize liberty
人们确实会来到这座小山。吸引苏特罗来到这里的同样原因也吸引着遛狗者和城市漫步者来到这里。也许通过这些讨论，我们真的能让某人决定建造一个新的雕像。我的意思是，谁知道它会是什么样子呢？想象一下关于如何象征自由的辩论
and philanthropy. Yeah, I don't know if I would like to see anything else here. Does that make me weird? Okay, I know. I mean, that is... then what we should have here is a little plaque telling people that there was once this beautiful sculpture to light and liberty and philanthropy,
和慈善。是的，我不知道我是不是还想在这里看到别的什么。这让我显得很怪异吗？好吧，我知道。我的意思是，那是……那么我们这里应该有一个小牌匾，告诉人们这里曾经有这座美丽的雕塑，献给光明、自由和慈善，
and now it's gone. So that's what we need to work on. Although a sense of mystery is always good, people look up and think, what could have been up there? What is missing? 99% invisible is about the stories of human-made objects and maybe in this case the absence of the object makes for a better
而现在它消失了。所以这就是我们需要努力的方向。尽管神秘感总是好的，人们抬头看时会想，上面曾经有什么？缺少了什么？《99%隐形》讲述的是人造物的故事，也许在这个例子中，物体的缺失创造了一个更好的
story. A monument to learning and light and liberty that's missing is almost a more amazing monument that says more about us. About just neglect and how a city forgets its past. 99% invisible was produced by me Mars, with support from Lunar. It's a product of K-A-L-W, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. Find out more and see pictures at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
故事。一个失踪的关于学习、光明和自由的纪念碑，几乎是一个更令人惊叹的纪念碑，它更能说明我们自己。关于漠视以及城市如何遗忘其过去。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持。它是KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的出品。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息并查看图片。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。